[Music]
[Music]
today we are doing the okay today we're
doing the first annual video game
Olympics hopefully it'll go every year
today we're going against no I guess
they call themselves the land party crew
we're playing four different games and
then we paid two people from each team
to play each game and until the fourth
one we're all gonna get a one person one
there's been a long time the making but
ever since we kind of both stir gaming
channels that we started around a
similar time Smosh games and us we
wanted to get together and do a big
collaboration when we played together
and because it's basically something
we've done in the past but never really
filmed or we want to actually finally
doing and film it and do it and so it's
finally happening today we're very
excited to show the Smosh games guys
that we I'm not sure how it started I'm
sure it came up a lot of times between
us and them because we're both gaming
channels and we both you know we love
their stuff and they hopefully don't
hate us and so it just seemed to make
sense to collaborate with them and make
some kickass video game videos number
one it's the will of people that first
and foremost in all of our concerns
number two I wouldn't describe this of
collaboration I would describe this as a
bare-knuckle brawl right it's a
collaboration to the extent that
punching someone digitally in the face
can be considered a collaboration it's a
meeting of minds and fists we got to
make sure that people don't kill
themselves and I'm watching you I play
video games for six weeks straight with
no sleeping which probably explains why
I'm sick right now I'm sick for the
competition but I was good to go for the
other six weeks
hardcore 24 hours a day gaming my
thumb's are bloody right now rubber
thumbs
I mean will appear friendlies on the
outside but really we just want to crush
them and just obliterate them and and
that's what we set out to do today
my nemesis was most definitely I got to
take that
I'm emotionally prepared for this by
leaving in some pretty nasty voicemails
now thinking those it was for me but you
know a lot trash talk a lot of lot of
push-ups I don't know how that would
have anything to do with this but other
than that a lot of sitting around and
thinking about our new games it's
probably good it's a mental game or
anything else for me
we've been practicing and that we've
been playing video games and thought our
videos as well as our own time but not
we didn't actually know what games were
gonna play until right up beforehand so
we have another practice their games all
right Anthony you're gonna do this it's
gonna look fab you day yeah
I'm team captain I'm failing my team
really terribly I think they're gonna
fire me or like chase me out of here
with the state stakes not like me but
like stinks a fire yeah I think they
will Kuby could be really hard I am
playing Halo 4 which should be
interesting
and I'm also playing Mario Kart which
it's the Wii Mario Kart which means that
it was made so like a 2 year old that is
playing it can still win that's it's
really terrible it's gonna be bad so who
could who knows who could win I could
play blindfolded I probably would not
there's no trees here I did plan on
hiding up in a tree and then just
waiting it out so I don't starve to
death so I'm going to be the designated
halo players walls Mario Kart I'm pretty
good mario kario she is my guy I would
be riding Yoshi a lot be like fruit
eating off of trees a lot of lot of
defecation of eggs baby Yoshis kind of
weird kind of his own thing
Yoshi kind of calls the shots usually if
you're ending an elephant and a lot of
its riding and quietly and hallo
I haven't actually played the new halo
but I'm gonna guess it's not too much
different than an old ones there's gonna
be controls going through TVs so yeah
the winnings very important for us
obviously but they're both running the
same page in terms of they both like we
both truly enjoy it in our very
but we play it together you know that's
the big thing our our channel we're
always always gonna bow we played
together it's not it's not just one
person playing and talking to a camera
it's it's for playing together it's
collaborative that's how we grew up with
gamesman and ian Anthony that's how they
grew up with games too is always because
we kind of love the slightly older
generation where we played when we had
to play multi-player we did go online we
went over to a friend's house and play
it you know late night all night
sleepovers with 60 boys and just playing
so but you kind of look like Satan it's
it's super fun I hope we're gonna have
one video each channel I hope they watch
both I don't know I think they can take
away the fact that it's super fun to
collab with other people and make videos
together play games playing games is fun
there's probably not much that they
could take from from the collaboration
other than I hope they didn't kill
themselves while they watched it what is
reality you know what is the difference
between what we perceive and what's
actuated in the world around us who's to
say that's thank you everyone can stand
their own farts but that's the weird
thing it's like it's like if you fart
like it's it's like you know it sucks
but you know you can still deal with
your own fart but if it's somebody
else's far like salt snake I think we
probably sell some crime together you
know we probably go we probably start
with a little dinner probably see some
crime in action and then after
pretty much you know go off and solve it
usually they just air him a lot I'm
pretty mad I didn't get to do that